from yosemite's iconic green valley
to its secret eastern edge
the little rain reaches this arid
landscape
blocked by over 13 000 feet of solid
sierra nevada
an alien desert-like habitat
home to one of the park's strangest
females
a praying mantis
[Music]
it's the last days of summer in yosemite
and she's coming to the end of her
seasonal feeding spree
her main weapons
prominent front legs lined with shark
tooth shaped spikes
[Music]
the praying mantis is the only insect on
the planet with three-dimensional vision
[Music]
her lightning fast strike clocks at 1
20th of a second
but this is only a cricket drumstick
appetizer
she releases a concoction of alluring
pheromones into the air
oh dumantas
one lucky guy picks up the signal
[Music]
maybe some eye contact can smooth out
this first date
[Music]
or maybe not
[Applause]
in exchange for his would-be wooing
the casanova is attacked
[Music]
it's impossible for him to free himself
the male's head is ripped off
[Music]
the female's final main course
it's an abrupt end to a first date
or is it
the decapitated male is still moving
[Music]
the headless torso of the male praying
mantis is still controlled
by nerves in the abdomen
[Music]
in a final mating act his body completes
what his head started
[Music]
the female on the other hand is busy
finishing dinner
she'll mate with multiple males each
breeding season
not all of them will suffer the same
fate
but the males who are decapitated
may father the most eggs
the ultimate sacrifice in a unique
yosemite love story
[Music]
you